We conclude the Iliad today. All right.
So remember that the Iliad it's a war of
wills. So the epic starts with the
battle between Agamenon and Achilles.
And um they're trying to impose their
will on each other and it leads to
disaster for the Greeks because Hector
and the Trojans are now about to destroy
them. And the Greeks led by Odysius come
to Achilles ship and beg him to return
to the battlefield. But Achilles wants
Aman to come and apologize and kneel
before him which man is not going to do.
So Achilles says no. But this leads to
um a conundrum because Eggman is going
to apologize. The children are going to
come destroy the Greeks. Achilles needs
uh Eggman to apologize in order to save
face. All right. So the Greeks and
Achilles are all very anxious. So what
Achilles does is he sends Petroas to get
the Greece to come and beg some more.
Right. But Netor understands what
Achilles is doing. He refuses to
apologize, but he tells Petroas,
"Listen, we can't get Achilles to fight,
but maybe you can fight for us, and
maybe that will save the day now."
Protas is very excited, okay? Because he
he's went all his life to outshine
Achilles because all his life he's been
in Achilles shadow, right? But now his
problem is how does how does he convince
his superior his commander Achilles to
go with a plan. Okay. So, so this leads
to a conflict a battle of wills between
Metropolis and Achilles. And remember we
read the speech last week and I want us
to visualize
how the battle is being fought. Okay. So
this is Petro
[clears throat]
and this is Aelius.
>> [snorts]
>> And if you if you read the speech, we
will discover that this battle is being
fought at three levels. Okay? There is
the conscious
um emotional level.
Okay? Then there is the calculating
manipulative
and then there is the strategic.
Okay. Planning level. All right. So
imagine three different individuals
together in Petropolis. The first person
is the actor. Okay. The person who
appears before Petroles and cries like a
girl, right? Then there's the
calculating which is like why am I doing
this? I'm doing this because I want
Achilles to agree
to me to join the battlefield against
the Trojans. Okay. And the strategic,
okay, the old wise man sitting in the
back is like, "Okay, what I'm gonna do
is I'm gonna convince Achil Achilles to
agree. Then I'm going to join the
battlefield and I'm going to win honor."
Okay, does it make sense? Okay, the
first person just appears before
Achilles and does the acting. Second
person is the one trying to explain the
direction. Okay, the third person is the
long-term
director. Okay. So, think of this as the
actor,
[clears throat]
director,
and producer. Okay? Or the investor.
What is my long-term gain from this?
Now, Achilles is the same, right?
Because Petroles cannot understand
Achilles mentality. Okay? So, the actor
in Achilles is like, "Why are you crying
Petroles? This is not our war. The
director in Achilles is ha maybe I can
trick Petropolis in helping me enter the
battlefield. Right? And the producer is
like
I want to win glory for myself.
Okay?
And it's all very subtle, but if you
read their dialogue, if you read the
debate, you'll recognize that this is
all happening at once. But not only
that, but if you examine your own life
and the decision decision you make, you
will recognize that you're doing all
three at once. Okay? Subconsciously.
All right? So [clears throat]
um Simon Freud would say that this is
the um id. Okay. The id is just the
basic desire, right? You want glory. You
want sex. You want money. Okay. There.
This is the super ego.
Okay. And this is the ego.
[clears throat] Okay. Or the maybe you
can think of this as the um conscious
subconscious.
All right. So, we've known for a long
time that we as humans operate at many
different levels all at once. And so, we
don't really know why we do what we do.
Okay?
And so they are having this fight and
it's all at a very subconscious level.
And what Achilles does is he says
something to Petetrois which as I said
before it's very weird what he says to
Petroles. Ultimately he agrees to um
Petroles is going and that's all he has
to do. Okay. Then nothing would happen.
Petus goes he faces Hector. He realized
Hector is stronger than he is and he
retreats. Right?
That's what should have happened and
that's what Neestor and the Greeks
expect to happen. All right? And then
Prous comes and Achilles recognizes that
he needs to join a battlefield because
Hector is too strong. Okay? That's
what's being planned. But what Achilles
does is he adds an element to it which
changes the
dynamic of events. Okay? which changes
how things unfold. Okay, so uh Ivory,
can you read this?
>> Once you have whipped the enemy from the
fleet, you must come back, Petroculus.
Even if Zeus, defending Lord of Hera,
lets you seize your glory, you must not
burn from for war against these Trojans.
>> Okay, stop. Okay, this is what's
happening.
Achilles is implanting into Petetro some
new ideas. And these new ideas is, "Oh
my god, Petolis, once you enter the
battlefield, Zeus,
okay, Zeus
is going to give you glory."
All right, he's getting excited. Pet is
hoping to win some glory on the
battlefield to prove his worth, to prove
at least he's equal to Achilles. But
Achilles is saying, "Oh my god,
Petroles, it's possible that you could
be better than me. It's possible that
Zeus himself anoints you the greatest
warrior in the world. It's possible,
Petroles, that you win all the glory for
yourself."
Okay, keep keep on reading.
>> Mad men lusting for battle. Not without
me. You will only make
>> Okay, so do not outshine me, Petropolis.
I know all your life you've wanted to be
better than me or at least prove you're
my equal. But don't do that, man. Okay,
I'm warning you. Do not prove you're
better than me. Keep on going.
>> You'll only make my glory that much
less.
>> Okay?
>> You [clears throat] must not lo you you
must not lost in the flesh and fire of
triumph, slaughtering Trojans outright.
Drive your troops to Troy.
>> So imagine this, Protasus. Once you
enter the battlefield, everyone's going
to love you. You're going to kill
Trojans one by one, but don't do that
because you will make me look bad. Okay.
>> What if one of the gods who never die
comes down from Olympus Heights to
intervene in battle? The deadly archer
loves his Trojans dearly. No, you must
turn back soon as you bring the light of
victory to the ships. Let the rest of
them cut themselves to pieces on the
plane. Oh, it's a to God, Father Zeus,
Athena, and Lord Apollo. Not one of all
these Trojans could flee his death. Not
one. No Argive either. But we could
stride from the slaughter so we could
bring Troy's hallowed crown of towers
toppling down around us. You and I
alone.
>> Okay. So this little speech, okay, it's
almost impossible to see to the naked
eye. But it dooms.
Okay? Because what it does, it tells
Petroas, Petroles, you have the
opportunity to seek eternal glory. You
have the opportunity to be better than
me. In fact, you're probably better than
me. Okay? And that gives Petropolis
hubris, right? And hubris is what's
going to get him killed because he will
challenge Hector. Okay?
Okay. Nowhere does
Achilles in this speech say, "Be aware
of Hector." Okay.
All he says is, "Hey, Zeus is gonna
support you and you'll be better than
me." Okay? Now, if Achilles is stronger
than Hector, Petroles can be stronger
than Hector.
All right? [snorts]
And why does Achilles do this? Achilles
understands that Petroles, if he's
young, he's impetuous, he's jealous. If
you give it opportunity, he will see
glory for himself and therefore he might
get himself killed. And you know what?
If he kills himself or he gets himself
killed, good for me, Achilles, right?
Because now
I have the perfect excuse to join the
battlefield when win all the glory for
myself. Okay, you understand? And this
is impossible to see.
No one, the Greeks don't see this. The
gods can't see this, but Tro himself
can't see this. And Achilles himself
doesn't know he's doing this. You
understand?
Okay. So, the question for us then is
how does this happen? How are we able to
function at three different levels
and do things that are invisible to
ourselves and to others? All right. How
is it that we make decisions? How is it
that we manipulate other people as well
ourselves? Okay, does that make sense?
That's a question before us today. All
right, so let's look at the standard
understanding
of psychology. Okay, so remember what
happens is this. We have experiences
and then we turn this experience into
memories
and memories are really emotions. Okay.
And then these emotions are organized in
a way that creates a identity.
All right? And different memories
[clears throat] can create different
identities. And together we create the
world view which is basically our
personality or how we perceive the
world. And our personality determines uh
our preferences, what we like, how we
how we make decisions and how we
perceive the future. Okay. All right. So
this is a standard model of psychology
which you should you should have learned
in psychology class, right? All right.
There's certain issues with this. The
first issue is
how do you filter experiences?
We can have all the same experiences but
the way we perceive the experiences are
different which leads to different
memories. Okay. So what is the mechanism
that allows for filtering? Okay. Second
problem is that
we know that memories are malible and
flexible. They're always changing. Okay,
that's weird.
All right, so it's possible over the
course of your lifetime you go back to
the same event, but each time you
perceive it differently, which causes
different emotional reaction in you. All
right.
So why is that the case? So for example,
maybe you know when you were young, your
dad hit you by accident. Okay? And at
first you really hurt and you perceived
it as your dad doesn't love you. But
maybe then when you get older and you
have your own child, you hit your child
accidentally and then you feel sympathy
for your father. Okay? Do you
understand? So the memory changes
according to your own development. So
why does that happen? Okay. The third
thing is
that you have imagination.
So we know from memories you can expand
them outwards and create new worlds and
universes. That's how we create novels.
That's how you write essays. Okay? But
how do you do that? Right? Cuz your
material is limited. But the imagination
is unlimited.
All right? So there are clearly some
issues with the standard model of
consciousness. All right. Now this
semester we've learned a new model of
conscious consciousness. So let's take
that model and apply it to the Ilia and
explain why they behave the way they do.
All right. Okay.
So
the model that we use is from Kant
and Kant says that [snorts]
rather being a passive observer of the
world
meaning that we just absorb experiences
and children memories we are active
participants in reality meaning that we
create reality. Okay. [snorts]
And so through space and time,
okay, [snorts] which can be influenced
by language
and media,
okay? Um, we turn nana
the things into themselves, okay? But
the things themselves are just
vibrations energy. Okay? Into the
phenomena things to us.
Okay? Now there are certain problems
with this model. The first problem of
course is um where does our space and
time come from? Okay, we know that we
create space and time in our brains but
why do our brains do that and what's the
mechanism in our brain that does that?
Okay, number two is [clears throat]
what is the na right?
We can't see it but what is it? The
third thing of course is if this is all
subjective meaning that we all create
our own reality how do we know we're
creating creating the same reality okay
[snorts] and so to solve this problem
hey
proposes this okay
is the gist
spirit um and the gist is what gives us
space and time all Right? So as we are
interacting with the nana, the nana
itself
re responds to us. Okay? Does it make
sense? And that's how we can all see the
same thing because it's the same force
that we're acting on. Okay? So this is a
bit confusing. So so let's let's look at
what what the Greeks say. Okay. [snorts]
[cough and clears throat]
So um
the Greeks have a metaphor for this.
Okay. The metaphor is this.
Imagine infinite number of people. Okay.
And the consciousness extends
infinitely.
Okay. So different dimensions, different
waves. All right. So on one level you
are just talking to yourself. But
another level you're talking to another
person. On another level you're talking
to more people. Okay. This goes on and
on infinitely.
All right. Now
remember that as you engage the guys,
the guys talks back to you. Okay. What
this means is that think of the internet
where
um whatever you produce is stored online
but you also have some memory in on your
own hardware. Okay. All right. So this
creates memories.
Okay. So your memories is now part of
the gist.
And as a result, the guys is constantly
evolving as you evolve as well. All
right? So it's like the internet. It's
dynamic. It's not set. As you engage the
internet, the internet changes. Okay?
And so what happens is that
um
these memories are stored in the guys.
Some are permanent because these
memories are extremely um visual or very
powerful. Okay. And that gives rise to
new consciousness like gods.
Okay. And there are higher gods. All
right. So these are maybe new gods.
[clears throat]
>> [snorts]
>> But then you have the old gods.
All right? And so the higher you go,
there are different um consciousness or
different um spirits. So the new gods
are gods like Zeus, Apollo, Aphrodite.
They actually interfere in human events.
Okay. The old gods are older gods that
have been there since the beginning of
time. And there are things like um
honor,
um [clears throat]
uh justice, fate,
destiny.
Okay? And they're stronger than the new
gods. Okay? But then you go up higher
and you have God itself.
All right? And how how can we understand
God? We understand God as the immutable
and unwritten
laws of the universe. Okay, we don't
know what they are, but they're like
gravity. They're going to be there to
structure the universe. And so, think of
them as like good and truth, [snorts]
okay? And beauty. All right? So, there
are different levels to this, right?
Why? Because as we
engage the universe, the universe
evolves and we implant our memories into
the universe. So even though we die, our
memories are still there and they're
still living. We can access them at any
time. Okay. So what is interesting about
this is that the infinity of the
universe is also
[clears throat]
captured in us.
Okay,
we are a hologram of the universe,
right? So the internet is vast, right?
But on our computers, we have a
hologram, a replica of the entire
internet. All right? Because we
connected to it all the time. We engage
in it all the time. So in other words,
whatever we do here, okay, impacts the
entire universe.
Whatever we do here will have uh rep
reparations throughout the entire
universe, throughout all of humanity.
One good act by yourself can impact the
entire universe itself because universe
is conscious. Okay.
Now we understand why Petetroas and
Achilles are able to do what they do.
Because if this is the universe, if this
is our consciousness, then there are
different spirits working within us. You
understand? And so we are constantly
able to
um sorry let me do [snorts] this to
operate at different dimensions.
Okay.
We're able to see far ahead. We're able
to uh focus on on right now we're able
to um be strategic and occupy different
people. Okay. We are literally a
universe onto ourselves. Does that make
sense? Okay. All right. So, you're like,
"Okay, uh, I don't think this makes
sense." Well, if you read the Iliad,
okay,
Homer actually reveals to you how this
works. Okay, that's what poetry is.
Poetry is a snapshot of this universe in
motion. All right. So, what we're going
to do is
we're going to read together the shield
of Achilles.
All right.
So, remember Petroles is dead,
but Petroles took Achilles armor to the
battlefield. So, Achilles has no armor.
So, he talks to his mother Thetus. And
Thetus goes talk to Heesus, the great
armorer of the gods in up in Mount
Olympus. And m and physicists is going
to design a shield for Achilles that
will make him invincible.
And the shield has living images. It's
like a movie. Okay? It's not a picture.
It's a movie where the images are
constantly appearing over and over. All
right. So I I this this is only a part
of the skew. Okay. Can you read this?
>> And he forged a fellow field. Broadri
plow land tilted tilled forward the
third time and across a cruise of plow
men wheeled their teams driving them up
and back and soon as they'd reach the
end straight.
>> Okay, so really important guys. Okay,
he's using a lot of verbs, right? Which
says that this thing is in motion,
right? You can see how they're moving.
Um teal,
sorry, teal.
Teal for the third time. Okay. So you
can imagine the first and second time
crews of plowman wheel their teams uh
driving them. Okay. Moving. Okay. Okay.
Do you understand? It's all motion. It's
all living. This is what our memories
are. Our memories are constantly images
in motion, changing, reacting. Okay.
Imagining. Okay. Keep on going.
A man would run up quickly and hand them
a cup of honeyed
mellow wine as the crews would turn back
down along the furrows, pressing again
to reach the end of the deep fow field
and the earth turned black behind them
like earth churning.
>> I can't really read uh uh churning solid
gold as it was. That was the wonder of
Hephis' work.
>> Wait, keep on going. And he forged a
king's estate where harvesters labored,
reaping the ripe grain, swinging their
witted sky. Some stalks fell in line
with the reapers, row on row, and others
to sheep binders skirted round with
ropes. Three binders standing over the
sheavs. Behind them, boys gathering up
the cutswaffs, filling their arms,
supplying grain to the binders, endless
bundles. And there in the midst the king
stepped her in hand at the at the head
of the reaping rose stood tall in
silence rejoicing in his heart. And off
to the side beneath a spreading oak the
heralds were setting out the harvest
feast. They were dressing a great ox
they had slaughtered while attendant
women poured out barley generous
glistening handful strewn for the
reaper's midday meal.
>> Okay. So we said that this shield of
Achilles is actually the soul of
Achilles. Okay. what his consciousness
is, what is inside his what is inside
him. And what this is ultimately is a
universe onto itself, right? You have
lots of different characters,
right? The king, um the woman, okay,
just lots and lots of people, okay? It's
a universe onto itself.
And we know the soul is composed of
memories. What this is telling us is
that these memories don't come from our
experiences. These memories comes from
partner experiences but also comes from
the universe itself. Okay, these
experiences, these memories only allow
us to access the universe in dialogue
with it. And as a result, we're able to
absorb memories from elsewhere. Another
way to understand this is that we are
constantly living and dying. Okay, when
we die, all we're doing is really
shedding our own bodies and assuming new
bodies. But our memories stay with us.
Our experiences stay with us. The poetry
in us stays with us and it's constantly
being rewritten. Okay? And that's where
our power comes from. Our power, our
will to live, our will to fight comes
from the fact that we are conscious
beings constantly in dialogue with the
universe. That that is both infinite and
internal. Okay? And this is what this
poetry represents. Right?
Does it make sense to you guys? All
right. So, this is only a snapshot, but
you know, he goes on and on which tells
us that we are extremely complex,
sensitive and multifaceted beings. We
are the universe ourselves. Okay? Our
consciousness is the universe. The
universe is our consciousness. It's all
interconnected.
All right?
Does that make sense to you guys? Okay?
All right. So this is an idea we'll come
back to later when we read the other
great books. Okay. All right. But um
something something that I want to
discuss is this. All right. So Achilles
jumps [snorts] in the battlefield and he
he kills Hector. All right. And at this
point Achilles should be happy because
he's killed the great Hector which
proves that Achilles is the greatest
warrior in the world. He's now secured
eternal fame. But then he does something
really weird. He decides to mutilate
Hector's body. He ties Hector's body to
his chariot and runs um goes around the
city of Troy and that causes Pry and
Hecuba, the parents of Hector to go
insane.
Okay, they're screaming at this devil.
And the Greeks, okay, Odysius are
disgusted because for them, Hector is a
great warrior. You respect a great
warrior. You do not humiliate mutilate a
great war like that. Okay. Hector fought
well on the battlefield. He never
cheated. He was just fierce and he was
great. So he was respected among
everyone. Okay. Also when Achilles
jumped back from the battlefield, Hector
didn't run away. Hector stood his ground
and died. Right? Everyone else ran back
in the state of Troy. But Hector is
like, "No, I must take responsibility
for this defeat." So he stands
um outside the gates of Troy. Everyone's
turning for Hector, come back you idiot.
A kill is going to kill you. And
Hector's like, no, I must face the
consequence of my action. Which is the
greatest act of bravery in the Iliad,
right? Cuz he knows he knows he's going
to die. So everyone's everyone's looking
at this and saying this is really
terrible. Okay, so what's happened is
Achilles has gone insane. That's the
only explanation for it. And the Greeks
try to comfort Achilles by holding this
funeral games for Petetro, right? But
that doesn't really solve the problem.
And now Achilles is in depre. He's
depressed basically. He can't sleep. He
can't eat.
He can't even cry for his friend. He's
so overburdened by guilt. Okay. So that
is the issue where you are connected
with the universe. Okay. The universe is
conscious. You are the universe itself.
So when you make when you do evil, okay,
and he knows, he he in his heart knows
he's the one who got Petroles killed. He
manipulated Petetrois into his death.
Then you know because the universe knows
and this haunts you for the rest of your
life. Okay? You cannot escape it. So
when you do evil, God doesn't have to
punish you because you punish yourself
with a memory of it. Okay?
Your soul burns with regret and despair
and guilt and shame. Hey, does that make
sense? All right. So now you have this
other conflict emerging in the Iliad,
which is okay,
Achilles is about to go insane. He can't
sleep, but he doesn't know what he did
wrong. He cannot admit that what he did
because he doesn't understand himself.
Okay.
So what happens now now is interesting
because if you read the Iliad the gods
decide that they have this great meeting
okay and decide that you know what we're
going to broker a piece between Pry and
Achilles. Hermes comes and takes Pry
into the Greek camp and then Pry and
Achilles meet. Okay. And and and this
comes this is the ending of the Iliad.
But then the question then is how does
that happen? Okay. Is this being
metaphorical or is it being literal? My
argument to you to is that it is
literal. Okay. So, let's explain how
this works. All right. So,
[clears throat]
this is Achilles.
This is Pry.
Okay. They hate each other. They could
not be further apart. Okay.
>> [snorts]
>> But then you have everyone else.
If you go back to this model, okay,
[snorts]
at some point, okay, Achilles and Pry
their thoughts will converge together.
Okay, but this is the universe. So there
are other consciousness within this
universe
and they see the conflict in here and
they will now engage in a dialogue to
resolve the differences
between prime Achilles. Okay. And these
are called the gods, right?
Okay. Doesn't make sense. The universe
is full of these different memories that
are constantly living and therefore they
can engage in debate, dialogue and
imagination. Okay. And so what they say
is, "Hey,
Prime and Achilles, you need to come to
agreement." And then subconsciously
Achilles knows, okay, you know what?
Prime's going to come and talk to me.
And Prime's like, I need to go and see
Achilles. Okay.
And now what happens is the universe has
come to an agreement. And so therefore,
the universe now will
um create a reality around this
agreement. Okay? Okay, does that make
sense? So, what this means is a a prime
can now walk directly from Troy to the
Greek camp. And what the Greeks will do
is walk away and pretend they didn't see
Prime. Does that make sense, guys?
Because the universe has instructed
them, Prime and Achilles must meet.
Therefore, you must make it possible for
them to meet. So then, you know, the
guard is sitting around. Prime's walking
this way. He's like, hm, I should turn
that way. And then prime walks walks
past him. Does it make sense guys? Okay.
Because we are again in constant
dialogue with the universe. The universe
has a plan. Then we must obey this plan.
Okay? And in China we call this what?
The mandate of heaven. Right? The
mandate of heaven.
It is the will of the gods that prime
and Achilles must meet and reconcile
their differences so that the universe
can continue on. Okay? Otherwise, the
universe must stop at this point because
Achilles is not going to give up
Hector's body. Prime will only suffer
because of this. Okay? Do you
understand? And this is how the universe
works. It's unbelievable. You think
about it. Okay? But you think about it
really hard, it makes a lot of sense.
Why do events happen the way they do
when in China we say men of heaven
because it is God's will. Right?
Okay. How can we explain in China Maong
who's this peasant? He was able to win
this war and establish people's republic
of China. Not only that, but during this
war he never got injured once.
How do you explain that?
Okay. There's all these things that
happened in in history and these these
people come out of nowhere and like wait
a minute where did this guy come from?
How's he able to do what he does? The
mandate of heaven guys. Okay.
There is a consciousness universe.
There's a plan. There's an intention, a
design to it and we all participate in
its design. Okay. Right. The conflict
now is there's a great injustice in the
world where Achilles refuses to return
Hector's body to prior and so everyone
agrees both the Greeks and solders agree
we are going to pretend [clears throat]
that
we don't see them meeting okay does that
make sense
you guys do you guys understand what
what's happening all right okay so now
we come to what is recognized as the
greatest
sorry as the greatest ending in all of
literature. Okay, this is the final
battle between Pryime and Achilles.
This is the greatest battle in human
history, right? This these are two
people who hate each other. Prime saw
Achilles murder Hector, his beloved son.
But not only that, but Prime also
witnessed Achilles killed many many of
his sons. Okay? And for Achilles, prime
is the great enemy. The person who stole
uh Helen from the Greeks, the person who
start this war. So now they're going to
meet and this is the greatest battle in
the Iliad. Okay. So um I can you read
please.
>> The majestic king of Troy slipped past
the rest and kneeling down beside
Achilles claps clasped his knees and
kissed his hands. Their terrible
mankilling hands that has slaughtered
primes as many sons in battle. Okay. So
in the contrast, right,
Achilles
slaughtered many of Prime's sons in
battle. Okay. And what the Majestic King
of Troy does is he kneels,
kisses his hands. Okay? He kneels before
Achilles. Pry is out behind Achilles.
Prime could just take a dag and stab
Achilles in the neck and kill Achilles.
He doesn't do that. Instead, he kneels
before Achilles and kisses the hand, the
very hand who killed all of his sons.
All right, keep on going.
Awesome as when the grip of madness
seizes one who murders a man in his own
fatherland and flees abroad to foreign
shores to a wealthy noble host, and a
sense of marvel runs through all who see
him. So, Achilles marveled, beholding
majestic Pry. His men marveled too,
trading startled glances. But Pryam
prayed his heart out out to Achilles.
>> And what's the effect? Awesome. Okay.
Okay. Achilles, the great warrior who
bows to no one. He is stunned by this.
He is defeated by this. He is a by the
majesty of Pria. Okay. Greatness does
not come from defeating your enemies. It
comes from forgiving your enemies.
Right? This is an act. Okay? This one
act of kissing the hands of the man who
killed all his sons. It's going to
change the universe forever. Okay? One
action is going to change the entire
universe and bring and bring peace and
reconciliation to the world. All right.
Um, and not only is
um Achilles stunned, but so are everyone
around him. Okay,
his men marvel too. Okay, so this is
reverberating across the universe where
you're far away but like you feel as
though an earthquake has happened. You
feel as though something magical has
happened and it changes you for the
better. Okay. So remember what's
happened is what has happened when a
group of men ceases one who murders a
man in his own father land and flees or
brought to foreign shore. So a wealthy
noble holes and a sense of moral runs
for all who see him. Okay. So what so
there are people who do great murder.
Okay. And so they have to run away. Now
when they run away
the crime follows them. They become
slaves in the new land. But some people
are able to become successful in that
place. Okay? they're able to change
their fate. So what this is saying is
because Pry has the strength and the
courage to forgive his great enemy. He's
changing his fate. He's changing the
fate of the world around him. Okay? And
the idea here is as above
so below.
Right? And this is a great secret of the
universe. What we do today, what we do
at this moment [snorts] can change the
course of history because if what we do
is memorable, it will implant itself
throughout the universe and be there for
all future generations.
All right? And and that's what's
happening. Okay?
So what Homer is doing is he is drawing
from the universe this memory and
showing it to us. That's what the Iliad
is. Okay. Elilad is a depiction of the
universe in motion. A universe of
consciousness. All right. Okay. Keep on
reading. Uh I Ivory.
>> Remember your own father, great godlike,
as old as I am, past the threshold of
deadly old age. No doubt the countrymen
around him plague him now with no one
there to defend him. Beat away disaster.
No one. But at least he hears you're
still alive and his old heart rejoices.
Hopes rising day by day to see his
beloved son come sailing home from Troy.
But I, dear God, my life so cursed by
fate. I fathered hero sons in the wild
wide realm of Troy. And now not a single
one is left. I tell you. 50 sons I had
when the sons of Aia came. 19 born to me
from a single mother's womb and arrest
by other women in the palace. Many most
of them violent ours errors cut the
knees from under but one one was left me
to guard my walls my people the one you
killed the other day defending his
fatherland my Hector it's all for him
I've come to the ships now to win him
back from you I bring a priceless ransom
rever the gods Achilles pity me in my
own right remember [snorts] your own
father I deserve more pity
>> okay so prime is the greatest king in
the world why because he's been the
humble himself before Achilles, right?
Remember Agam Manon? This this this um
struggle started because Agame Manon
refuses to be humble. He refused to
admit that Achilles is right. He re
refuses
to um apologize to Achilles. Okay. Okay.
But Pryam is the opposite of Mega Man.
Okay. He's begging for Achilles
forgiveness even though he hates
Achilles. And why does he do this? What
gives him the power to ask for
forgiveness to beg Achilles? The answer
is his love for Hector. Right?
I He's doing this because he wants
Hector's body back. All right? So, what
animates what unifies this car universe
is love. Love is God, guys.
To really access this universe, to
really know this universe, you must
love. Okay,
love makes you invincible. And so Pry
has the courage to come to Achilles, but
he also has has the courage to beg
Achilles to forgive Achilles.
All right. And what Prime says is
remember your father Achilles, right?
Okay. As I love Hector,
you also love your father. And how and
and how does he know that? Because we're
all connected by the universe. Okay.
He's able to imagine the soul of
Achilles. He knows that how Achilles
loves his father, okay? As much as he
loves Hector. So this is what allows
them to come together.
All right. The love of Hector
makes prime imagine the love of Achilles
for his father. Right? And these are the
two forces. Love activates the
imagination.
[snorts]
[clears throat] Okay. So love is the
unifying force of universe. It brings us
all together. The imagination is the
animating force of universe. It makes
the universe alive. Okay. And that is
our purpose in this world to love each
other
and then to activate our imagination to
create the re the reality that that that
we live in. Okay. A world where the
pillar is love is perfect and it's just
all right. Keep on reading. Um Ivory,
>> I have endured what no one on earth has
ever done before. I put to lips the
hands of the man who killed myself.
>> Okay, so what he's saying is that this
is a unique moment in history. No one
has done this before, especially a king.
A king submits himself before the
murderer of his beloved son. All right?
And because it is unique because it is a
perfect distillation of a father's love
for
um his son. This will be remembered
forever. Okay? This will become now part
of the universe. And how? Because Homer
is able to access it. Okay, this might
have happened somewhere. He doesn't know
where. And this but this hap and this
might have happened between two people.
He doesn't know who. Okay, but he knows
this happened. He's able to draw on this
to create the Ilia. Do you understand?
The universe are the living memories of
great deeds.
And Homer is able to create this by
accessing this because they're all
within us if we allow it to
uh be in us. Okay, keep on going.
>> Those words stirred within Achilles a
deep desire to grieve for for his own
father.
>> Okay, so you see how how this works.
When you imagine things, you see the
truth for what it is. Okay, keep on
going. Taking the old man's hand, he g
he gently moved him back. And
overpowered by memory, both men gave way
to grief. Prime wept freely for man
killing Hector, throbbing, crouching
before Achilles's feet as Achilles
whipped himself. Now for his father, now
for Petraulus once again, and their
sobbing rose and fell throughout the
house. Then when brilliant Achilles had
had his feel of tears and longing for it
has left his mind and body.
>> Okay. So, okay. So what's happened is
that Pryam has defeated Achilles. Okay,
remember Achilles's great problem is he
can't cry. He can't he doesn't know what
he did wrong. He doesn't know how to
express his guilt and and shame. Okay.
But now that Prime has
forgiven him, Prime has actually
liberated Achilles. Okay. Before
Achilles, his soul was trapped in evil.
And now by forgiving [music] Achilles,
Prime has let his soul loose to
reconnect the universe and therefore to
return to its poetic self. Okay, keep on
going. [sighs]
Then uh he rose from his seat, raised
the old man by the hand, and filled with
pity now for his gray head and gray
beard, he spoke out wing words, flying
straight to the heart. Poor man, how
much you've borne. [snorts] Pain to
break the spirit. What daring brought
you down to the ships all alone to face
the glance of the man who killed your
sons. So many fine, brave boys. You have
a heart of iron. Come, please sit down
on this chair here.
>> Okay. And so now the And now this is a
resolution. Okay. This is the epiphany
of Achilles. He recognizes his guilt.
And now because Prime is able to forgive
him, he's able to forgive himself. And
so he's become wiser, more gentle, more
poetic, more generous. All right? And
this is what life is. This is what it
means to be human.
All right? To to do battle with our own
heart. Okay? So
um let me talk um about what this all
means like who are we why are we here
where are we going so in the Buddhist
and the Hindu tradition the idea is that
we are constantly
uh reincarnating okay and this world
that we live in it's one of pain it's
one one of suffering but it's one that
gives us insight. It's one that trains
us to be wise. It's one that allows us
to have the memories to create a more
divine universe. Okay? Um and we do that
because we we incarnate and we assume
different roles, right? So maybe in this
life we are the murderer,
then next life we are the murderer.
Okay? Maybe in this life we're a human.
next life we are a uh plant then the
next life is an animal but it goes on in
infinitely until we've achieved
wisdom okay so in other words
the point of this life is to develop
empathy
okay
because empathy leads to wisdom and
enlightenment
right But the great thing about a great
book is it's a universe onto itself and
therefore you can actually speed up the
process of wisdom enlightenment because
by reading the Iliad you can assume
different lives. You can have different
lives all at once. Okay, does that make
sense? So what makes Iliad so powerful
is that you're constantly switching
perspectives. Once today you're Eggman,
then you're Achilles, then you're
Hector. Okay. And what's amazing is that
he Homer is a Greek and he's speaking
for the Greeks. But it ends from the
perspective of the Trojans. Okay. It
ends with Pry getting back Hector's
body, taking it back to Troy and
everyone in Troy coming to see the body
and crying. Okay. Especially
uh the wife of Hector Atrom Mackey.
Okay. So uh so this is this this is the
ending. Okay. C can you read? He he is
prime. Okay.
>> So he calls and the crowds fell back on
either side making way for the for the
wagon.
>> So everyone's coming and crying over
Hector's body but he but he tells them
to move away. Okay. Because they need to
bury the body properly. So they so
people depart like the sea and heck and
Prime is able to move the body forward.
Keep on going. [snorts]
>> Once they had borne him into the famous
holes, they laid his body down on his
large carved bed and set him set beside
him singers to lead off the laments and
their voices rose in grief. They lifted
the dirt high as the women wailed in
answer. and white armed armed andro
>> Andrew Maki
>> Andrew Maki led their songs of sorrow
cradling the head of Hector man killing
Hector gently in his in her arms. Oh my
husband cut off from life so young. You
leave me a widow lost in the royal halls
and the boy a lonely b only a baby. The
son we bore together. You and I so
doomed. I cannot think that he will ever
come to manhood. Long before that, the
city will be sacked, plundered top to
bottom. Because you are dead, her great
guardian. You who always defended Troy,
who kept her loyal wives and helpless
children safe. All who will be soon
carried who will soon be carried off in
the hol ships and I with them.
>> Okay, so this is how it ends. It ends be
it ends with a prophecy. Okay, and this
prophecy will turn out to be accurate
where the son of Hector will die because
that that's the way of war. Okay. When a
city is conquered, all the men and all
children are killed and all the women
are enslaved. Okay. So, this is Enaki
saying, "I'm going to be enslaved." And
this is the coming of the Trojan horse,
right? So, the great hero
of the Tro the Trojans, Hector, is now
dead. So, the Greeks are going to come
and destroy all Troy. So, you're a
Greek, okay? And
all your life you've heard about the
great victory of the Greeks against the
Trojans. Okay, the Trojan War is the
most famous story in your life. Now
suddenly this guy Homer
he tells you about he asked you to
imagine what it's like to be a Trojan
woman knowing that in a few months your
entire city will be sacked.
Your husband will be killed. Your
children will be murdered. And you'll be
put on a on a on a ship to be enslaved
while you watch your city burn. Okay?
Think about the power of that.
Okay?
Think about what's happening in
Gaza, in Palestine today, right? Where
the Israelis are bombing
uh the Palestinians. They're killing a
lot of children
and they think it's right that we do so
because we are defending our land.
Now imagine one day they have a dream
and they imagine themselves as the
Palestinian who's being attacked for no
reason. As a child who's lost his
mother. As a mother who's lost her
child. Think about the emotional impact
on that. Okay.
What this is is the big bang of
civilization.
Because when you read this, okay, when
you're forced to switch perspectives,
it's a violent assault on your own
consciousness, your prejudice, your
beliefs,
your values all being destroyed at once,
which allows you to access the entirety
of the universe. Okay? Does that make
sense? Only through trauma, only through
pain, only through suffering can you
access empathy and wisdom. And that's a
great truth of the Iliad. But also this
is why the Iliad has to be a lifelong
journey because it will take you a life
life entire life to appreciate the
nuance, the beauty, the power of the
Iliad. It will take you a lifetime to
understand the motivations,
the uh psychology of all the characters.
Okay? These are all living beings. But
if you were to spend your entire life
doing so, I guarantee you, you will come
out a much more wise person who now has
a universe in your soul and that will
make you invincible
and eternal. Okay? But it's your choice.
Okay? All right. That's it for the
Iliad. Uh we we'll start the Odyssey
next. Okay. Which is a continuation of
the um Iliad. Any questions?
Ask
a question, guys. Come on.
You guys understand this? Does it make
sense to you?
I'm going to ask a question to make to
to make sure you understand what's
what's going on.
[snorts]
Okay. All right. All right. This was a
lot to take in. Um but this will stay
with you for the rest of your life.
Okay? So over time this will become much
much more clear. All right. So we start
the honesty next class. Okay.